[Music]
he faces bobby thompson
here comes franco's second pitch and
it's gone thompson connects and the ball
crashes into the left field stands
for a stunning three-run homer 1951 was
a banner year for baseball bobby
thompson
shot heard round the world set up a
world series between the new york giants
and new york yankees featuring future
hall of famers
willie mays a retiring joe dimaggio and
a 19 year old
named mickey mantle it was also the
first year that
tops then just a chewing gum company
began making baseball cards
while the look and feel of the cards
have changed over the decades
one thing has not 70 years later tops
still brings us closer to the game
and its players
welcome to the jones residents this
idaho falls garage
is a baseball treasure chest okay this
is box
b 22 it's where 35 year old
paul jones doug bossler a former las
vegas stars pitcher
known in the card collecting community
as foul ball paul
keeps his meticulously organized
collection of
3 million baseball cards people's
jaws drop when they see my collection it
extends to the family's basement
a memorabilia museum paul's father barry
gave us a tour
and this is just one row it's on this
side
he has more
it's taken paul a lifetime to amass
where does your love of baseball cards
come from i was born with a learning
disability and disorder
it teaches me geography spelling math
history you could definitely learn from
them so when you pick up a card that
maybe you collected when you were eight
what is actually seeing and holding that
physical card what does that do for you
it brings back memories and joy and
happiness
paul's passion is shared by countless
others it's
it's like a rite of spring when you see
the first baseball card packs
like steve mandy who owns attack of the
baseball cards in union new jersey
and says the pandemic sparked a renewed
interest in trading cards
it seemed like a lot of the guys were
home for a month or so
until their wives finally got on them
and said what are you going to do with
all these cards that you have piled up
in the closet
and the guys took out their cards that
they had from the 1980s and 90s and
started looking through them they
decided maybe i should start collecting
again
you can trace the card collecting hobby
back to of all
things a candy company tops
top students start as a trading card
business
started as a gum company and then they
needed to figure out a way to sell more
gum
these machines can even count the number
of cards going into each pack
so they put trading cards along with the
gun that was 1951 when
topps produced the first set of what
would become modern day baseball cards
clay larosky is the company's vice
president of product development
the love affair started when i was about
four or five years old and i would go
underneath my brother's bed and i'd open
up that
that shoe box and there are all these
baseball cards in there
and i've been fascinated with it ever
since take a card leave a card
in sharing some of top's rich history
lerosky pointed out the 1951 cards
featured just a fraction of big league
players
it wasn't until 1952 that the first
complete set was released
and featured the holy grail for card
collectors
they now routinely sell for millions of
dollars
in 1952 they were just trying to get rid
of these cards trying to sell off this
inventory
and at some point a gentleman by the
name of cyber decided to uh
to rent a barge and go out here at the
end of manhattan
and dump tons and tons of 1952 baseball
cards in there
in baseball mickey mantle but topps did
find a way soon after
to build a loyal audience of baseball
fans
in 1952 if you're living
somewhere where only like touch point
with baseball if you're lucky is a
television
a black and white television right but
it's probably a newspaper
so now you're walking into a store and
you're opening up a pack of cards
and you're getting these full color
photos of willie mays
mickey mantle like your heroes it just
brought the player closer to the
collector and the fan
and then this one is my very first card
even when the fan
is a player i got the bb face going on
pat nishik suited up for seven different
major league teams in his 13-year career
for tops this is my first tops card but
he never got over his affinity
for card collecting your love of
baseball cards where did that start
so it started like any kid in the 80s
like when i was like six seven eight
years old
it was cool because like we would see
those guys and try to pretend that we
were them
and it was really cool like opening the
card seeing the logos of the different
teams and following my stars
the stars that i liked during his big
league playing days
nashek took his childhood hobby one step
further
using his access to other players to
amass an unrivaled stockpile
of autographed cars he got trout right
there but the one card he treasures most
isn't worth much more than the cardboard
it's printed on
you know my favorite player was kirby
puckett yeah that's i didn't have
much money when i was little and i
wanted to save up money to buy
kirby puckett's rookie card well one of
my friends had it and i stepped on his
kirby pucket card and he went nuts
and he was like you need to buy me a new
one and so i
i said i think it was like 20 dollars i
had to save up i don't know if you could
see the ben but
and so i bought him the card and i gave
it to him but he gave me
the bent card it transported me to that
moment
as it's been from nearly the beginning a
two and a half inch by three and a half
inch rectangular time machine
transporting collectors even if it's
only a matter of days
like with top's now series featuring
current moments from major league games
available almost
instantly like miguel cabrera's snowy
opening day home run
or this stray cat in the outfield at
coors field
we're taking a photo uploading it to a
design
printing the cards overnight and putting
them in your hand
this is so cool innovation lerosky says
a key to top's
70 years of success celebrated with this
season's project
70 series classic baseball cards
recreated
by artists this is a continuous theme in
my work
stripes dots and then chevron new york
graffiti artist claw money
is one of them i don't think of myself
as a sports person
okay but i grew up in a mets family
she showed us her card designs featuring
new york baseball legends
don mattingly doc gooden tom seaver
and the soon to be released thurman
munson
i picked people from new york because
that's sort of my reference point
that were heroes to my
friends to my dad to my uncle's favorite
player my sister's favorite player
but i feel like i'm really like becoming
a baseball fan
through this project really yeah just
because of being involved with the cards
just because
of the cards this week tops also entered
the nft market with limited edition
digital cards tracked and authenticated
with blockchain technology
but leraski says top's focus remains the
same
trading cards in their essence it's a
connection right
to your player to a moment it's like a
marker on a timeline
that doesn't go away no matter what
virtual world we create
for us now that never goes away as long
as there's an image
whether it's digital or whether it's
physical it doesn't go away
all because they wanted to sell more gum
because they wanted to sell them workout
now the gum no longer exists in the
cards but our producer
tony dipole there was able to purchase
some 1989 packs
we're opening a 32-year old
but it has baseball cards if you find a
ken griffey junior rookie card in here
it's his tony has claimed because it's
worth tens of thousands of dollars
don't don't chew the gum it's from 1980
i'll try it okay jeff will try
by the way follow paul told me he's
never had a tops card made of him
so you know a little hint to tops we
created one yeah you're chewing the gum
there it is the foul ball paul tops
trading cards should it ever be created
and gum will not
be in it for him i got aussie smith i
got phelps
yeah jose rijo and uh